今日は弾み社長ですというわけ
謎に好評なまで
飽きてしまいました第三大事故物件
一人で泊まってみた
いったい陰に帰ってきましたがついに今回
3回目でございます
的服部改まらないんですけれども1回目2
回目皆さんとか見られましたかまだの方が
よなんかあるかなとしてみてください1回
2回目は結構 the 事故物件長さも
事件か何かあって本当には使われてなくて
結構雰囲気とか場所し雰囲気が高いですね
事故物件距離を打つい強い幼虫2回させて
いただいたんですけど今会話月今までも
勝つだったんだけど今回は月の本当に比較
的綺麗なな逆にきれいだからこそ怖いん
ですよフィン人も誰もない本当にしっかり
と事件があった事故物件木そちらも許可を
すっかりと得て撮影しております
[音楽]
俺だって最後第一スタッフないっていう
なかなかネス5物件です影響があっており
が来てよく撮れたなって感じで生きるん
だったらいこうと思って俺にできることを
しようと思って今晩こちらに取らせて
いただきたいと思いますしずライフライン
をつなげられるようにしてもらっているの
で1回電気つけます
[音楽]
青谷ば本当に
無理かもプロバですに底までやると注意点
がこれか
いきますはい
つきましたつきましたついては意外と普通
の家の感じがありますね
なんだいるの具体ページに何があったかを
説明させていただきますそもそもこのを
やる何があったかというとこの部屋を
おかげしていた家族の方が自殺されたと
いうこの井岡していたボムなーさんが by
チェックしたいとあって通る会社がこの
要素のも買って良かった会社さんに米撮影
許可をいただいたという感じで今こそして
いただいておりますありがとうございます
どういうこと
をが住んでいるのかどういうがあって
亡くなったか分からないんですけど曲に声
何があった場所でも何もなく過ごせたら
全然問題ないことも逆に俺はねもう今回何
も起きてほしくないという感覚で着てい
ますつーわけで早速止めていこうと思い
ますこっちが県間で多く入ったら大きな
部屋が1個ありますチューブでちょっと外
は移せないんですけどもこういう感じのん
ですね全然じまもなく普通のお家ですハイ
ピッチですっキッズも別にね何か特別
変わったこともないむしろ綺麗なんじゃ
ないのパパっですね今までの事故物件が
ヤラセ見て尺2年下さ強い場所で強い稼働
綺麗な当たり前なんですけどもこういう
普通のきれいな場所で強いこともあっ
たっていう実はめちゃくちゃ濃い開け t
だけでいいよこの受けますね
4を
ああああああ
和室だめっちゃ綺麗として保存しますねっ
着せきれいな画質がありましたね本当に
事件があったのかどうかぐらいの綺麗さ
ただ事件があったのはこの部屋ではない
みたいです
いきますここがあった
といいですね
トイレますにつきます
twitter
なにこの後
何できる所0号 jal のというわけで
この部屋が実際に事件だったお部屋です
むちゃくちゃ綺麗ですけども事実として
やっぱり事件があったというわけです
綺麗だしこれほんと良い道なんだよ聞いた
はず塗るとここらへんかなここなんかなぁ
ことなんかななんかここら辺で亡くなられ
たっていう話は聞いたんちょっと開けてみ
ますねじゃあ失礼します
ああああああうん
me
ストラー鳥肌が
4枚
です
女へとかいやーここらへんません
はいすいませんもうあの北鬼江喧嘩です
ここで間違いなさそうですねああここが9
ドア麦芽を破壊されてるんだと赤いテープ
の猫ドア爆が破壊されてこれ
なんで行くとワクワクとれたんだろう意味
不明すぎる
もっと普通にきたし
他にざっと読みましたけど1000名以上
ですね
[音楽]
作ります
こうついてついてツイート
普通に go すごい一関節痛みどうぞ
そんなに変わったことはないけど
締めといてよ
こんなもんねに基本的な部屋は今まで
みたいに一軒家とかじゃなくてほんと
アパートの一室であった絶対ますので
そんなにたくさん見るべきところはないん
ですが4に今回国の活動拠点ショートする
部屋はこの事件があった置くようにします
いや逆にね自分にそういう事件とか誰かが
亡くなったとかあって実際にご自身で見て
何も起きなければ何ら問題はないんですよ
思い込みに過ぎないつを負わせるためにも
多くが責任をもって
何かあったら怖い花その時はその時考え
ます基本的には事故物件に住んでも何も
ないよ大丈夫記事ないですねっていうのが
僕の持論なんで取れ腐食せざるに今回一晩
泊まってみたいと思いますこれねー
俺やばいよね何回も言いますけど本
っっっっトニー嫌なんですよこんなパト
入る前に玄関で15分立ち止まってた勇気
が出なくて本当に避けしてには事故物件に
来ておいています
ああああああ
寝袋を持ってきましたし
[音楽]
寝る人ねーなー今日ぞと塗るね小磯編集の
パソコン版がお水もう少ししたら夜ご飯
食べたいで近くお店で買ってきます
[音楽]
はいっ
待って待って待って java ちゃう
ちょっと待った止まったと思ったとなった
となった止まっ
のっ
青い海なんてまぁちょっと通ってるの
スマスマで普通にカメラずという
いや払いずっと一緒な字八北になんでだ
なんで止まったんだそもそもずっと老化し
てたんですよこれまってなんでこのため
通ってるの
永遠と蔓瞬間が止まっています
iphone 止まることなんてあるの
ちょっと待ってよ
だんだんやはり普通に吐きそう
あっ
まず
[音楽]
抜けちゃっ瞬間と思います細巻前に撮った
と思うんですよ俺一切触ってないから止め
のボタンを iphone のバージョン
ビルズドプレートオンにするからもう最新
の状態になってるんですよこれでさぁ
カメラ止めるってだろう
すごくないん
[音楽]
って
海底
こんなの骨にねん6寿たらさ
おおーー
ちょっとやなぁ
はいあれから
[音楽]
部屋から出れなくなりました
多分外へ出ると帰ってきたくなさすぎって
を帰ってこれなくなるかなと思って今結構
見解の成人状態でこの辺にいます
時間23時58分もう間もなく日付が
変わりますよく言われるのが日付が変わる
さの深夜の0時あと2分ですね何かおける
んでしょうか結構強がってて今がんばって
いるだけで実は結構
メンタルぎりぎりでやってますパターンっ
日付が変わりました
0すっかりです
見てまいりましょう
どんな問題だし
洗面所がは軽くて結構仲メンター安らぎ
ます水まわりって一番例が倒れられている
んですよちょっと細いですよねぴっちゃん
です
大丈夫このさあ
ほいみわかんないよね何だろうなんか祭る
というか神様とかに多くの所っぽいです
けど
指導画質2
[音楽]
雨よねー
今朝はだと思います子供が破壊したり24
つ
特に
大丈夫そうだ気はします
今中道って聞こえた気がしたんだけど
[音楽]
手芸
ただ
この部屋だなぁ
ブレーカーの下ないんですけれどこの部屋
にすごいは明らかにしつつ
山狩り超えたということでいますかないん
ごはんを買ってきます
来那すごいねコンビニ行ったら一瞬で元気
が戻ったやっぱ人っ気がある場所へ行くと
年各近畿もらえて復刊しましたその2を
帰ってきたような形で復帰上げて今日の
夜ご飯は気持ちいいの誰がいないので自由
カルビやげ肉カレーじゃリーのとり二羽
ずつポーカー今日酒飲んでないで言って
られません1人と耐えられないお酒飲み
ます病は気からということで腸内環境を
整えたあればブザーとにアイスの日です
今回はこのセットアップで事故物件に戦っ
ていきたいとおもいますいただきます
pa
ん
住まいどこで食っても旨いもんは旨い
うーん
かっさ
tan
[音楽]
r
ん
ポンポン持っ
[音楽]
でもっ
ね
おはようございます
あれていますはいはいそれで廃業がです
はいございますというわけで朝になります
毎回思うけど俺すごいなぁ今回も今の
ところですけれどもいろいろありました
けどもチョップ時に今のところが大丈夫
だったっていう感じですね
何もなかったてたらちょっと厳しいかも
しれないですけどわからない夜偶然とかも
あるんでわかんないけど郡築物件に泊まら
せて頂きました
[音楽]
ふぅ